Ramsey solutions Rob and Katie are with
us from Hartford Connecticut hey guys
how are you
hi Dave we're doing well that's a bit of
a haul from Connecticut to Nashville a
little bit Wow
well welcome and here to do your
debt-free scream thank you how much have
you guys paid off we've paid off
$167,000 how long did that take took us
two years Oh about a year ago we paid
off the last hundred seven thousand
which was a huge step Wow I guess so
what's your household income about 160
did it start like that what did it start
out at 77 okay so it's over doubled Wow
so what do you guys do for a living I'm
a nurse practitioner
mm-hmm and I'm working for diesel engine
company and testing engines and then I
do dock business on the side so
everything ducks ah okay and so how did
you double your income during this time
I graduated oh okay in the hundred and
sixty-seven thousand how much of that
was student loans 166 and I think I know
whose student loans they were her name
might be Katie I'm not sure okay very
cool all right so that was the idea you
came out of school and then you guys
just really laid into this oh I mean you
hit it hard you the way I'm hearing this
story it sounds like you cash flowed
this tell me what happened and we also
cashflow to our wedding at the same time
you got married about two years ago no
there you go we started out separate and
then we got married and June 2014
oh okay and then that's when it kicked
into gear yeah okay our big time it's
October that's when we paid off 107 Wow
what's so impressive I mean you guys
have been on beans and rice yeah I mean
really where people making fun of you I
don't think they saw us enough to make
fun of us so although my family got it
in work work work work work work lots of
hours yes hour lots of overtime if
overtime wasn't there I don't think we
would have done it
no you just you really piled it on man
that's amazing we
fabulous income or at least the
potential to make a fabulous income
because you've made one you may want to
crank it down a little and breathe again
now how's that feel to have that to
knock out something you you climb Mount
Everest in two and a half years this is
amazing yeah it was it was definitely it
was hard
we started basically my aunt Amy gave my
father the book to read a few you know
when I was in grad school and it never
was something that you know my father
mentioned in passing oh you know maybe
you should read this but he wasn't he
was one of these people that was like
you know it would be nice but so I
didn't really think about reading it
until I realized what a mess I was in
the last year of grad school and about
to graduate and what the heck are we
gonna do so then I we were gonna get
married showed it to Rob and we got
married so basically getting to the
wedding was the big thing and then we
got to the wedding we got married and uh
a couple months later we found out I was
pregnant so then we started piling up
cash and everything like that and it was
like huge you know surprise and we
didn't pile up cash for very long a
short time later we found out I was
gonna miscarry and then it was basically
an emotional rollercoaster and the whole
thing was kind of an honor not only of
our first child but you know future
children God willing yeah absolutely
Wow so you guys have been through a lot
in two years yeah a little bit I mean
this is Wow kind of like threw ourselves
into work gotcha Matt yeah yeah Wow but
it was it was a wonderful journey of
communication and really brought us on
the same path I mean we kind of didn't
even know what to do with ourselves but
this gave us something to do Wow very
cool so when someone hears you paid off
167 thousand dollars and they hear how
did you do that what do you tell them
the secret is I'd say
working hard and just you know ghazal
intensity that was huge for us they
definitely
when we saw the debt it was easy at
first as their like $500 Louis thousand
dollar loans so we paid those off and we
just kept going bigger and bigger loans
and then the hardest part was about
halfway through when you're looking at
loans that are you know $10,000 like wow
this is taking forever to pay off and
you just keep pushing through and then
you get another one paid off like I got
three or four left and you just keep
going keep going and you know by May
June this year we we knew we were gonna
do it faster than we thought we would
and it felt really good yeah you can see
the finish line is closer than you
thought of when you look up
oh yeah that's amazing so when you sat
at the bottom of this mountain
originally looking up now you're on top
of the mountain and you've done the
journey was it easier or harder than you
thought it was gonna be at the beginning
at the beginning is opening you use the
mountain we were on a hike yesterday
kind of thinking about everything we're
in this huge you know whatever your huge
Tennessee parks and you know I'm from
Rhode Island where our state we can
drive through 20 minutes so we of course
you know an hour two hours into the walk
we got lost lost the trail you know no
idea where we were and Tennessee and
kind of here banjo music now are both of
our reactions are pretty typical for how
the whole journey went you know I'm
looking left and right seeing what we
can forage because we're gonna die in
this woods and Rob is calmly taking out
the map and seeing setting but so I
think Rob really you know it was a lot
of me kind of freaking out we're not
doing this fast enough you didn't though
obviously Rob was saying he was a
marathon or euro sprinter yes exactly
yeah he's a planner
lauter and you guys are perfect for each
other yeah Larry Burkett used to say if
two people just alike get married one of
yous unnecessary so you guys really got
this down congratulations you guys I'm
very very much the opposite of like
public display of affection tight
person but you know rob was doing docks
every weekend he was going to school two
nights a week
he was calming me down he was you know
really great person to do this Wow Wow
well you married well both of you did
both thank you congratulations very well
done man this Rockstar stuff right here
all right Robin Katie Hartford
Connecticut a hundred and sixty seven
thousand dollars paid off in two years
making 77 but now making 160 the
future's bright count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one word
love it love it I love it I love it well
done
man that's great